so I'm asked one question most often why
didn't you sell your business it doesn't
even make money by deleting the images
after you sent them we changed what it
meant to take a picture I think one of
the perks of being a really small
company is that from the beginning we
got to think about diversity he's an
American internet entrepreneur he's the
co-founder and CEO of the mobile app
snapchat he has an estimated net worth
of 2.1 billion dollars
he's Evan Spiegel and here is my take on
his top ten rules for success rule
number five is my personal favorite and
I'm curious if you're great which one
you guys like the best as always if
everyone is saying something that really
resonates with you please leave it down
in the comments below
and put quotes around it so others can
be inspired as well so I'm asked one
question
most often why didn't you sell your
business it doesn't even make money it's
a fad you could be on a boat right now
everybody loves boats what is wrong with
you and I'm now convinced that the
fastest way to figure out if you're
doing something that is truly important
to you is to find is to find someone who
will offer you a bunch of money to part
with it see the best thing is that no
matter whether or not you sell you will
learn something very valuable about
yourself if you sell you will know
immediately that it wasn't the right
dream anyways and if you don't sell
you're probably on to something maybe
you have the beginning of something
meaningful
after you worry about making the leap
from sort of an inventor to a manager
and how are you handling that yeah well
I think the the solution really is the
team right and so Bobby and I both have
lean really heavily on some really
terrific people that we've been able to
hire and frankly I think that's that's
the only way to do it I think the
challenging part from like the learning
perspective is making commitments that
are that big at such a young age to the
people that work for us and their
families it's very hard for me to use my
phone to be honest I'm kind of like on
text message and email and our service
and so I'm always yelling at our people
to try and hopefully not yelling but
trying to encouraging big early
I know it was really vigorous
encouragement yeah um to to make this
service just more and more simple so
every time we add a new feature we try
to take a button away and that's that
sort of has spawned a lot of our
inventions like we have it we have a one
camera button on our service and you can
tap it to take a photo but if you want
to take a video you just press and hold
and that you know in the past if you
remember or still happens on a lot of
camera phones today you have to switch
into video mode and you end up with all
these like weird like videos that you
thought were pictures pictures you
thought your videos doesn't really
doesn't ly make sense so we're much more
interested in increasing engagement
rather than getting big so we really
focused on a few markets that are really
really important to us and right now
we're working on really increasing
engagements making making sure the
people that are on our service just love
it and that's really what we watch and I
think over time we'll think about
expanding the product but right now it's
really just a maniacal focus on making
great products and deepening the
engagement with our service you already
have inside of you all of the amazing
things you need to follow the dreams
that you have and if you get stuck along
the way there is a ton of free
information available on the Internet
have faith in yourself and the person
you're going to become know that you are
capable of all of the growth that will
be expected of you and that you expect
from yourself you will tackle every
challenge headed your way and if you
don't it won't be for lack of trying
someone will always have an opinion
about you whatever you do won't ever be
enough so find something important to
you find something that you love you
really found something special in
snapchat which at the time was called
piccaboo and we found that by deleting
the images after you sent them we
changed what it meant to take a picture
so a picture wasn't about saving a
really important moment it was about
communicating and we got really lucky
because smartphones and their camera
connected to the Internet
meant that there was really a big change
happening in communication that we you
know didn't didn't totally identify at
the time but we do now which is that
people prefer to communicate with photos
and videos
rather than pack diversity for us is
really closely tied to competency so for
us we have such a diverse group of
people using our products and services
every day that in order for us to make
absolutely great products and services
for that community we need a really
really diverse group of people and it's
really that simple so for us we just
have an awareness that you know if we
want to make the best products we need
to have we need to have a diverse so can
you describe your diverse group of
people and I mean what are some of the
percentages if you have them and again
like this this is sort of the challenge
and I should I should have exact
percentages for you but we just don't
think about diversity and in terms of
numbers that way and I think one of the
perks of being a really small company is
that from the beginning we got to think
about diversity so we didn't end up with
a situation where ten years down the
line oh my gosh I need to fix my numbers
because it's not really cool to think
about people as numbers right we think
about people and diverse skill sets and
so for us because you know we're 300
people now we were thirty people
gosh a year and a half ago we've been
really mindful that as we grow we need
to hire diverse folks in for Matias so
fascinating and it's so pervasive that
it's been studied for a very long time
see it turns out there are two things
that can dramatically reduce conformity
in a group setting the first is a single
dissenting voice and the second is the
ability to communicate privately with
other members of the group our
government gives us the right to privacy
and the right to express ourselves
freely in the hope that we might
mitigate conformity democracy wasn't
designed to promote popular thought it
was architected to protect dissent for
as President Kennedy said conformity is
the jailer of freedom and the enemy of
growth what circumstances were present
that made this idea catch fire sure so I
think there was sort of two components
in the first component is probably that
social media was starting to feel a
little stale so there's only so many
beautiful attractive cool pictures that
you can take and when you see all of
them day after day after day it just
kind of gets bore
so I think there was that aspect of it
and then I think the other thing is that
we really identified that this ephemeral
thing was core to conversation and so if
you want to have a conversation one of
the best parts about it was that you
were left with the memory but not
necessarily a transcript and I think
that that really drove the great feeling
that you have when you you know share
snaps with friends and they're silly and
you know not exactly perfect you know
there was obviously a place for all
these great photos that you wanted to
save and keep and there wasn't so much a
place to have a conversation and I think
you know there's a nice balance with
both and so I think we sort of filled
maybe avoid the conversation void that
was missing I'm obsessed with this idea
of no standard terms so when we when we
were first getting started and took took
financing or our lawyers would take us
through the documents and they'd say oh
you don't worry about it it's all
standard then at the time I'm like oh
sure standard that's great no no issues
senator centers no problem and I've
since learned that standard means either
the person who's walking through the
documents doesn't understand them or you
could be getting taken advantage of so
when someone says something standard
just ask why and why and why and why
until you really understand you know
intricately I think how how the deal
structured and so I I think the big
thing that we took away from that is you
know standard terms is a huge red flag
and beyond that just afraid to just
continue asking why thank you guys so
much for watching I made this video
because Prasad Marne or marnai I hope I
got that okay ask me too so if there's a
famous entrepreneur that you want me to
profile next leave it down in the
comments below and I'll see what I can
do I also love to know which of the 10
rules had the biggest impact on you and
why what change you're going to make
what was the most touching after
watching this video what are you can
apply to your life in your business
leave it down in the comments and I will
join in the discussion thank you guys so
much for watching
continue to believe or whatever you're
one where it is and I'll see you soon